who got the most incredible jury
collection me being real boots don't you
definitely have to go to man who's had a
big super long chains you know ain't
this good man hoochie man he actually
was the one I aspire this ya ask for the
king of jury and you got the king
escucha bang on the rocks
I've been infatuated with jurors as a
young age I think I got my first piece I
had to be like six or seven maybe eight
my father was a con man he always liked
trick people like like money and jury
and I go to school and I'd be like the
only kid they'd have like a necklace
I've been iced out since a little boy
like for real
I didn't bring a lot of jury today but I
brought some really just want to show
off my new [ __ ] I brought three of my
diamond bracelets take off our set and
quavo these are three amigos everything
they do is platinum all three of these
are platinum right here all the 1.5
carats of piece right here so you know
it's like a quarter million dollars
easily I got them 1017 change all three
of them they go so hard on the jury they
pushing me when they make something that
should be fired
no matter how many chance I got every
like damn I'm gonna come up with another
chunk
okay this bracelet right here is like a
another tennis bracelet rose gold with
Sean's hanging on it I got made but then
I went back and got the change made with
it you're looking at another like for a
million dollars they know play play [ __ ]
right here
I wanna [ __ ] like where it's like 300
400 500 600 thousand no play no games
brings us two watches this is what you
call the Big Dawg this ap right here is
varied over $1,000,000 I had to get this
from a dude we had to go to auction for
this in Beijing because I really wanted
it it's a big gear AP from AP so like a
lot of people can't say they got this
watch right here the best jury GILF I
ever giving somebody definitely my wife
I gave her like crazy wedding ring and I
just bought a watch the other day like
last week of poj cold my favorite piece
of jewelry was my first ice cream cone
my Bart Simpson and my new ice cream
cone I did showing my hair and me like
80 grand back in the day we just wanted
to have the biggest piece ever you don't
send any kind of getting to be like
classy so I felt like it's a like a good
combination of like the old with the new
no one to get like real good time it's
real good quality but I still wanted to
do like you know the ice cream cone that
beer money you know trademark I just
felt like when I got the tattoo I want
to be different you know I want to be
unique and I went to like the most
extreme measure that do it I was wanting
to have the best tattoos the best jury I
was wanting had the best interviews I
wanted to have the dopest flyest girl
the fly's car when I got in the rap game
don't like what I set out to do this is
my new signature
it's like shoot your shot you know what
I'm saying if I like something I always
like go up on somebody page 10 is emoji
so spend them 200 grand just let you
know I think I think some dope
I got to tender change
see mine I got vvh stones in the night
and they two carats of peace
I love these like I said these my
diamond tender change all of them to
carats of peace across two carats of
peace so the stones so big and huge like
I separates me from everybody else you
can't even compare them to me you have
to go get like an athlete or owner of a
basketball team to compare cheer with me
[Music]
lately I've been wearing mostly like
white and rose though because I feel
like it's just oversaturated with yellow
go right now even though I love yellow
girl it was beautiful only I just want
to be different
very buddy start wearing white I don't
know even though I don't like black eyes
as well black I just don't want to do
what everybody else doing I'll make you
like having fun man I feel like when I
go in the studio I go in there just to
talk about Bali you know I'm saying I'm
in the [ __ ] the ball ain't in here to be
playing ain't in it to be depressed so
yeah don't be talking about what I'm
doing and I'm gonna be flexing this is
my wedding ring my wife makes got this
woman I cherish you just like the one
piece I don't care if I have on a yellow
watch or white watch the road watch
I'm mad at wedding rings oh it's so
pretty to me I'm like I wanted matching
pink ring then I started thinking about
him like [ __ ] I want to get up I want
to get a pic and ring that crush
everybody and that's this dis right here
this ring right here five hundred
thousand dollars just one ring this
stone right here it's 15 carats just by
itself not including the stones around
it I don't want to keep playing games I
see like ruffles they help seven eight
rings on just get one [ __ ] ring and
then you got my earrings I just bought
some new earrings I don't even want to
speak on them they set me back so much I
don't even want to tell you how much
that cost
you wouldn't believe me and I don't
think it's a good thing to tell people I
don't I just went
it's okay to shine it's okay to reward
yourself it's okay to have fun and it's
okay to help people as well but more you
have the more you can help
so keep running your money over King
shine